en france on dit toujours la culture la
culture et les bonnes mais je ne
souviens autrefois chez mon grand-père
il y avait accroché dans le salon
3 mené 3 2 gars 3 renoir de somptueuses
tapisseries
dieu merci c'est moi qui ont hérité
après beaucoup de discussions et bien
qu'ils épousseter chaque jour ses
magnifiques tableaux c'étaient les mômes
il y avait de quoi leur forme et vous
semble et les porcelaines de sens
telefoot est les canapés louis saez la
splendide bibliothèque ont monté moi mon
oreiller nissan à la spa
et l'argenterie cristaux les bibelots
libye joue c'était pas de la culture le
sondes aa comparables dont elle
bénéficiait gracieusement sans débourser
un centime
et les conversations à table si réplique
c'est un slot de l'élite dont elle
pouvait saisir des bribes on vole tout
en présentant les plats c'était pas de
la culture ballon laissez moi rire
voulez-vous me dire ce qu'elles font à
présent elle travaille à l'usiné où elle
fera quand n'importe quoi des portugais
elle se 30 dans le métro l'élève de la
marmaille gens soient bien du plaisir et
elle habite
je vous le demande en banlieue et
agréable dans un chu ils aiment
tellement hideux que moi passant devant
refuse de les voir au lieu de loger dans
une de ses chambres de service
pontcharra chape énorme et qu'on loue
très bien très bien les petits étudiants
charme elle ne voulait plus de nous
chambrer bien nous les avons reprises
ouah je vois dans mon immeuble je les ai
tout rafler et j'en ai fait un
appartement x qui me lis pas ce sont
très amusants qui ravit toulouse amis